[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر براكي
واحييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوابه
النصر يحول عمليته الخاصه لحرب شامله وكيف
تخشتهوره في ذكرى انطلاقه الحرب
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد دعم الرياض
لوقف النار في اليمن ويشدد على ان الحرب
يجب ان تنتهي بالتفاوض
اليوم نحن جزء من المطلوبه العربيه
حمله اعلاميه ضاريه في ايران
جديد وشك ليس في الضوء الاخضر ولكن في
غرضه
تابعون معنا ايضا
تسلم ماسه ماسك تتحول لكابوسه بدا محاكمته
بتهمه الاحتيال ومشروع القياده الذاتيه
يصطدم بالحائط
[موسيقى]
في تبرير جديد للعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن
انما تفعله قوته في اوكرانيا من خلال
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو محاوله لوقف
الحرب المستمره منذ 2014 وحمايه السكان
الذين يعيشون في تلك المناطق مشيرا الى ان
روسيا لم يكن امامها خيار
لم تتوقف العمليات القتاليه التي تشمل
الاسلحه الثقيله والمدفعيه والدبابات
والطائرات في دمباز منذ 2014 ما نقوم به
اليوم كجزء من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو
ومحاوله لوقف هذه الحرب وحمايه شعبنا الذي
يعيش في تلك المناطق لقد تحملنا لفتره
طويله وحاولنا التوصل الى اتفاق لكن تم
خداعنا وهذه ليست المره الاولى ومع ذلك
بدلنا قصار جهدنا لحل هذا الوضع بالوسائل
السلميه العدو كان يستعد لتحويل الصراع
برمته الى مرحله حاده وساخنه اكرر لم يكن
لدينا خيار سوى ان نفعل ما نقوم به الان
من جهته اوضح نائب الامين العام لحلف
الناتو ميرسي ياز جوانا ان روسيا تستعد
لحرب طويله في اوكرانيا مشيرا في الوقت
ذاته الى ان ايران تقوم بتزويد روسيا
بالمزيد من الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
روسيا امر خطير الرئيس الروسي يستعد لحرب
طويله وقد حشد بالفعل اكثر من 200,000
جندي اضافي كثير منهم قيد التدريب بوتين
يتوسعوا في الانتاج العسكري الروسي ويحصل
على المزيد من الاسلحه من الانظمه
الاستبداديه الاخرى بما في ذلك ايران ليس
لدينا ما يشير الى ان اهداف بروتين قد
تغيرت لذلك يجب ان نكون على كامل الجاهزيه
والاستعداد العام الحالي سيكون صعبا ونحن
بحاجه الى تقديم المزيد من الدعم
لاوكرانها
اذا 37 يوما تفصل روسيا واوكرانيا عن
الذكرى الاولى لانطلاق حرب ضروس بينهما في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي ذكرى لا
يتمنى اي طرف منهما الا ان يحتفل بها
منتصرا ولكن من سيبلغ نصاب الفوز ليس
واضحا لان كليهما يبذلان ما بوسعهما لنيل
هذا النصر روسيا كانت شنت لهجوم بدعوه
الحاجه الى نزع السلاح واجتثاث النازيه من
اوكرانيا اضافه الى منعها من الانضمام
للنيته وحمايه الروس الذين يقتلونه هناك
ومنذ اول انفجار شنته على مباني في كيافا
ظل تصف ما تقوم به بالعمليه الخاصه تصف
ودمار
وقتل واسلحه كل ذلك يدرج لدى موسكو
بالعمليه الخاصه حتى دموع هذا الصبي لا
تزال تمطر حزنا على فراق وطنه وابيه الذي
ابى الا ان تمزح عائلته ويدفعه عن ارضه
لكن وبعد مرور نحو احد عشر شهرا وجدت
روسيا نفسها بعيده عن تحقيق الهدف لانها
وجدت سدا منيعا من الاوكرانيين لم تكن
تتوقعه الدليل ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ولاول مره منذ بدا النزاع قال اننا
نواجه حربا وحربا طويله الامد زاد عليها
في تصريحات اليوم ان غرور القاده
الاوكرانيين لم يمكن من انهاء الحرب سلميه
لا اعلم ولكن اتمنى ان تنتهي قريبا
لكن لاظن انها ستنتهي هذا العام
ليس لدي اجابه
من القوه
نحن سننتصر
عندما يحدث لكم اننا في كل الاحوال لا
يمكن هزيمه الاوكرانيين
لا استطيع ان نخمن لكن سيحدث ذلك عاجلا ام
اجلا
لا احد يملك توقيتا بطبيعه الحال البعض
يملك امال فقط تقول صحيفه نيوزويك
الامريكيه ان روسيا بتتجه الان لتغيير
موقفها وتتعامل مع الواقع على ان ما يجري
في اوكرانيا حرب تقليديه كبرى ووفقه معهد
دراسه الحرب فان المعركه قد تصبح حربا
شامله يسخر فيها احد طرفين نزاع او كلاهما
معظم الثروات الماديه والبشريه المتوفره
للمجهود الحربي ومع اقتراب اليوم الذي حول
سماء اوكرانيا الى اجواء مدجزه بالطائرات
والمسيرات الحربيه تكثف كاف الدعوات الى
زياده امدادها بالاسلحه من الدول الغربيه
حيث
قالوف سكرتير مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني قال ان كيف تتوقع ان تحاول
القوات الروسيه القيام بما يسمى بالدفعه
الاخيره في الفكره العمليه العسكريه في
الرابع والعشرين من براير المقبل ووافقه
نيوز ويك فانا الكراملين كان قد اتخذ
تدبيره لتدارك اخطاء الحمله العسكريه
الروسيه بما في ذلك تعبئه نحو 300,000
جندي واجراءات صناعيه واقتصاديه لخدمه
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا حتى الان بل
ويدور حديث عن ان بوتن وضع تكليفات محدده
امام القائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا كاتيا توانيا
الروسيه في اوكرانيا من عامها الاول تزداد
تقارير الخبراء العسكريين والسياسيين التي
تتحدث عن التوقيت المحتمل في انتهاء
ويعرضون خيراتهم حول كيفيه التوصل الى
هدنه محتمله وحول ما اذا كانت ستنتهي قبل
الرابعه و20 من فبراير او في باريس كما
تحدث تقارير اوكرانيه عن ان الرئيس الروسي
اصدر تعليمات لقائد العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا للسيطر على دمباز بحلول شهر مارس
والتي رفض الكريم من التعليق عليها ومع
ذلك يتوقع خبراء وروس ان تقوم موسكو مع
حلول الصقيع بزياده العمليات الهجوميه
هناك والتي تعكس رغبه الرئيس الروسي
القديمه
الصراع في اقرب وقت ممكن كما تحدث مسبقا
اذا بدا بوتن كمن لدغ من جحر مره او مرتين
او ثلاثا لا فرق المهم والاكيد ان التغيير
يبدو مطلوبا الان وربما لهذا صيغه خطه
تبدو في طريقها للتنفيذ في طريقها للتنفيذ
اذن وعنوانها سيكون تعزيز الجيش بما اوتيت
موسكو من قوه استعدادا لحسم المعركه فبعد
سلسله من الانتكاسات قدم وزير الدفاع
سيرجيو جدولا زمنيا لزياده القوات ضمن
اجراءات واسعه النطاق في الفتره الممتده
من العام الجاري وحتى عام
2026 من الواضح ان الحرب ستكون طويله اذا
قال ان تعداد القوات المسلحه الروسيه سوف
يرتفع الى مليون ونصف مقارنه بمليون
و150,000 في العام الماضي اضافه الى
انشائي مناطق عسكريه جديده المناطق
المحيطه بالعاصمه موسكو وسان بيتروس بارك
على الحدود الانديه واكد المتحدث بس من
الرئاسه الروسيه
ان سبب زياده تعداد عسكريين يكمن في
تصرفات الغرب وضروره الضمان ان البلاد دون
قيد او شرط فيما اسمه حربا بالوكاله وعلى
حد تعبيره فكل الطواقم العسكريه تعمل على
قدم وساق على مدار الساعه لزياده قدراتها
العسكريه خاصه من اولئك المسؤولين عن
توريد الاسلحه وصناعتها وبعد تعيين
الجنرال فاليري جراسي موف كائد الاعلى
للحرب في اوكرانيا ستبدو امامه المهم اصعب
لانه قطع وعدا امام بوتن بان بان يستخدم
تكتيكات اكثر عدوانيه لكسر الجمودي على
الارض
لنتعرف على الواقع الميداني والسياسي من
كياف من الجانب الاوكرانيه معنا من كاف
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بك معنا
حذيفه اخر التطورات على الارض ما الذي تشي
به خاصه مع التصعيد الكبير بوعود الغرب
بالدبابات الثقيله اضافه الى ما همم ورد
على لسان مسؤولي موسكو اليوم والذي يبدو
تصعيدا همم يواجه به بوتين الوعود الغربيه
مساء الخير طاهر في الحقيقه يعني اليوم
زارت وزيره الدفاع الكنديه اكيد والتقت
بالكسيرزن كوف وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
واعلنت عن تقديم
مدرعه همم للجيش الاوكراني هذه كمرحله
اولى واعلن عن دعم عسكري كبير ودعم مالي
في الحقيقه للجيش الاوكراني طبعا هذه
الاموال التي تاتي من كندا توجه لشراء
الاسلحه همم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وغيرها من
الدول الشريكه لاكرانيا تعلم انه هنالك
يعني الان المرحله طاهر هي مرحله حجز
الموارد بين الجانبين كل جانب يحسد
الموارد كل جانب يقوم بالتدريبات الان
الاتحاد الروسي يقوم بمناورات على الحدود
الاوكرانيه سواء كان من اتجاه بلا روسيا
وكذلك بمناورات عسكريه
وكذابات
الاستراتيجي واا يتدرب ايضا على عمليات
الانزال
بالله عليك يرى الخبراء ويرى العسكريين
همم بان هذا تمهيدا لعمليه اجتياح كامل من
كل الجهات ولذلك هناك تدريب على عمليات
انزال وهم يتوقعون ان يكون هنالك عمليات
انزال حتى بالقرب من كيفه هذا طبعا ما حدث
سابقا في بدايه الحرب طبعا تعلم ان هنالك
موافقه على الدعم اوكرانيا بالدبابات ولكن
اليوم ايضا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعلنت عن حزمه مساعدات ضخمه وكبيره جدا
للجيش همم الاوكراني همم
تشيء بهذه المخاوف همم الاوكرانيه طبعا هي
تصريحات همم الان همم بعضها تصريحات من
روسيا وبعضها تحليلات ولكن مع اقتراب ذكرى
سنويه الاولى همم هل همم واضح على الارض
كيف يمكن ان تواجهك هذه المره
الاستعدادات من قبل كيف توحي بذلك وتشي
بان هنالك امرا يدبر الاستخبارات العسكريه
اكثر من مره تحدثت قائد الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تحدث اكثر من مره
بانهم لا يستبعدون ابدا عمليه اجتياح كامل
لذلك كنا قبل ايام قليله طاهر في الحدود
الاوكرانيه الفلل الروسيه ورصدنا عمليات
الاستعداد الواسعه والمراقبه للحدود حتى
في وقت وجودنا على الحدود كان ما زال
الجنود يعملون والخبراء يعملون على زرع
الالغام يعني امام عيونها كانوا يقومون
بعمليه الزرع الانغام هنالك تنظيم للجسور
الطرق الرئيسيه كذلك الغابات هناك قطع
الغابات الرئيسيه في مجال الرؤيه لمراقبه
الحدود كذلك همم مراقبه الاجواء على
الحدود هذا ايضا انا رصدته على جبهات
القتال في الشرطه
وغيرها ارى استعداد وحسن الموارد وراء
القوات يعني حشد القوات الاليات وللمدرعات
هذا بالاضافه الى الاسلحه الثقيله التي
الان يقوم الاتحاد الاوروبي والحلفه النيه
عفوا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
القرار قد اتخذوا الان نحن قد تفصيلنا
ايام عن اجتماع رمشتاين وهو اجتماع مجلس
همم
من وزراء دفاع الدول الشريكه المجلس
الاستشاري الامني لاوكرانيا وهذا ال- ال-
المجلس هو يجتمع لتقييم الحرب ولتقييم
طبيعه المساعدات التي همم يعني للمرحله
تحديدا وين الصلب عندما صرح وقال ان هذه
مرحله حاسمه في الحرب علينا ان نزود
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه اللازمه للنصر هذا طبعا
ياتي بنسبه لتصعيد الكبير من الجانب
والحشد الموارد من قبل الجانب الاتحاد
الروسي طبعا لا بد بسرعه طاهر يتبقى لك
وقت يعني اتحدث حول الحدث التي حدث اليوم
وزير الداخليه
نذكر المشاهدين بها ثم اسالك عنها شكرا لك
حذيفه في كل الاحوال اذا وق ان تستعد
اوكرانيا للقادم من المعارك عليها ان
تستوعب اولا صدمه خساره وزير الداخليه
وعدد من مسؤليها بلوا اطفال في عمر الزهور
في حادث سقوط مروحيه في منطقتك
[موسيقى]
اذا اخر المعلومات حول سقوط هذه المروحيه
حذيفه
يعني دينيس اولا هو يعني لم يقتل وزير
الداخليه فقط قتل في هذه المروحيه وفي هذه
الحادثه قياده وزاره الداخليه باكملها
يعني الوزير ونائب الوزير وزير الدوله
وكبار المستشارين في وزاره الداخليه لقوا
حتفهم في هذه الحادثه في سقوط هذه
المروحيه هذا من جانب طبعا تم تعيين ايجر
كل منكم وهو رئيس الشرطه الوطنيه
وزاره الداخليه طبعا الجميع يشهد ليمن
ستيرسكي بانه يعني رجال الدوله
نتحدث عن المناطق المسترده مع مساله
التعاون هنالك طبعا قضايا لمتعاونين
اوكرانيين مع الاتحاد الروسي وهنالك
القضايا وعمليات بحث تجري في المناطق
المسترده وتحدث
يعني استخدم هذا الامر اكثر من مره
الاعلام يعني كما يقول الامن الداخلي عن
الدع الروسيه دائما ما تستخدم هذا الامر
لاخافه الاوكرانيين انفسهم هذا من جانب من
جاء طبعا هذا الحادث اليوم في بريماري في
هذه في رياض الاطفال راحه ضحيته 14 شخصا
بينهم طفل واحد وهناك همم يعني حوالي 30
شخصا الان في يعني تلاقون الرعايه الصحيه
قالك كبير الاطباء في المستشفى الذي نقل
اليه الجرح قال ان لديه خمسه اشخاص همم
يعني في حاله حرجه ثلاثه اطفال في حاله
حرجه وشخصان بالغين همم في حاله حر رجاله
لديهم جروح في 30% من الجسد وكذلك جروح في
الجهاز التنفسي طبعا ما زال البحث همم وما
زال عمليات جاري الجهاز الامن الوطني يحقق
في ثلاثه فرضيات الفرضيه الاولى هو انتهاك
قواعد السلامه من قبل الطاقه والفرضيه
الثانيه هو ان يكون هناك عمليه تخريجيه
لهذه المروحيه اي انه تم اسقاطها عن قصد
وال الثالثه
ملاحظ انه يعني حتى الكسيكوليبا قائد
الاداره العسكريه عنده مثلا انه بشكل
مباشر هناك قال انه لا يستطيع ان يدلي باي
معلومات عدد من المسؤولين حاولنا ان
نسالهم لا يبدون باي معلومات وهذا طبعا
الربطه الناس بالحادث الاخيره حول
التصريحات الاخيره التي ادت في الاخر في
النهايه الى استقالته لذلك عن الجميع
ينتظر التحقيقات شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات من كيا في مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه ايضا في العربيه 360 في ملف وثائق
ماي تاون العدل لم تشارك بالتفتيش لان
قسما من محامي الوزاره منهم للرئيس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان انا سعوديه
تسعى لوقف اطلاق النار اطلاق النار
كونان لا يمكن انهاء الحرب الا من خلال حل
نتفق عليه وهذا ما نعمل عليه حاليا
المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده المعاني
باليمن موجود هنا وحكومه اليمن تسعى ايضا
لايجاد وسيله للاتفاق مع الحوثيين للوصول
الى وقف اطلاق النار والوصول الى نهايه
هذه الازمه
من جهته شدد المبعوث الامميه الى اليمن
هانز جراند بيرد على ضروره انهاء الصراع
في اليمن مؤكدا انه تسبب في معانات
الملايين مشيرا خلال جلسه نقاشيه في منتدى
دافوس الى ان الهدف هو ايجاد الوسيله
لتحقيق ذلك
الصراع في اليمن لا يخدم احدا ويتسبب في
المعاناه للملايين الهدف هو ايجاد وسيله
لانهاء الصراع كيف وعلى اي اسس هذه امور
يمكن تفاوض بشانها الخطوات التي تم
احرازها كانت ايجابيه في الاشهر الاخيره
حيث خفض صوت السلاح لكن الموضوع لم ينتهي
والطريق لا يزال طويلا
[موسيقى]
اثار التصريحات الرئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شيعه السوداني غضب ايران بعد تكراره
في عده مناسبات عباره الخليج العربي وبعد
تاكيده على التقارب مع محيط العراق العربي
ما فتح التساؤل حول مغزى مثل هذه
التصريحات وحول اسباب الهجوم الايراني
اليوم نحن جزء من المطلوبه العربيه ونحن
حريصون على استمراريه وديمومه علاقتنا مع
دول الخليج العربي
تولي رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني فتحت عليه نيران الجاره ايران
فبات بعدها متصدر لعناوين الصحفها سيل من
الالقاب المسيئه للسوداني والاتهامات
صريحه والمبطنه تاره بانكشاف ما كان يخفيه
من نوايا وتاره اخرى بالتخطيط الاستداره
العراقيه مفاجاه بوجه طهران بل ان البعض
ذهب ابعد من ذلك بطرح تساؤل حول ما اذا
كانت مواقف سوداني تمثل تهديدا لايران
ايران يبدو انها ضاقت ذرعا بتصريحات
السوداني المتتابعه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
خاصه وانها لم تفقد من ترديده عباره
الخليج العربي خلال افتتاح بطوله كاس
الخليج العربي الخامسه والعشرين فضلا عن
تايده لبقاء القوات الاجنبيه وفي القلب
منها الامريكيه لاستكمال مهمه تحرير داعش
هجوم الصحف الايرانيه اتى بعد ايام من
استدعاء طهران السفيره العراقيه لديها
للاحتجاج
لكن سؤال الاكبر الان لدى البعض هل تمثل
تصريحات السوداني تحولا سياسيا حقيقيا ام
انها تمت بتفهم داخل كتله الاطار التنسيقي
التي ايدت توليه المسؤوليه والتي يدين
اغلبها بالولاء لايران
معنا من بغداد دكتور حسين علاوي مستشار
رئيس الوزراء العراقي اهلا بك معنا همم
كيف
تردون اولا على ما تقوله الصحافه
الايرانيه وعلى ما يرد فيها من هجوم على
رئيس الوزراء
يعني مساء الخير عليكم مساء الخير على
المشاهدين الكرام اكيد هنالك فرق بين
المواقف الرسميه
والمواقف الغير الرسميه وبالتالي ما ينشر
فيها الصحف ان كانت اصوليه او اصلاحيه هي
تعبر عن وجهات نظر لكن عندما دققنا
حقيقتان في
الهيد لاين او المنشيه او العنوان وكذلك
محتوى هذه المقالات والاخبار كان هنالك
فرق حقيقه بينما نقل في الان في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي والترجمه همم كذلك من
اللغه الحيه الى اللغه العربيه وهذا
بالتالي ما يجعل المسار مسار مختلفه ان
كان همم بيتحدثون عن همم
اذا فهموا غلط
لا لا لا لا
تسمحلي سعد العلاقات الرسميه هي العلاقات
جيده وفعاله وممتازه بين العراق
وايران وكذلك بين العراق ودول الخليج في
مقدمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه والاردن
وكذلك تركيا هو المحيط الاعني لدول الجوار
العراقي وكذلك دول الخليج والمنطقه
العربيه هناك تفاعل كبير يعني جميل جدا بس
مع الدكتور حسين الموضوع الان الموضوع ما
كتبته الصحافه الايرانيه ما كتبته الصحافه
الايرانيه يعبر عن اراء مسؤولين يعني تبقى
موضوع اراء حره ثم قلت بانه بعدما دققنا
يعني حاولت معهم
مجالات حوار ثاني
لا لا قبل قبل ان ياتي قراءه حقيقه كل هذه
الصحف المنشور بها يعني عندما يشيرون او
يعني يتخذون باتجاه انه والهويه العربيه
همم في خطاب الدوله العراقيه الذي يتجدد
الان بصوره واضحه جدا نتيجه العمق العربي
والعمق الخليجي الذي تحدث عنه السيد رئيس
وزراء للسيد محمد الشاعر السوداني واضح
جدا انهم يقولون انه فرصه هو فرصه اللي
يحل المشاكل كذلك مع المنطقه عندما تقرا
المتنه وتعود مره اخرى حقيقه
وتقرا المتن هنالك الان حوار ايراني سعودي
وهنالك حوار ايراني عربي والعراق يرعى هذه
الحوارات حقيقتين همم من خلال التزام
الحكومه العراقيه بان يكون هناك همم
اقليميه مستقره وهذا في نقل المنطقه كذلك
من همم
لوجه ايران همم
صدام حسين همم
قالت السوداني خطوات صدام حسين انا ما
بعرف بس قراتها حاجه او اختصرته يعني
اذا ما قالوا كذبنا على الهواء اذا تسمح
لهم قالوا نعم نعم لا لا هم قالوا قالوا
هذا الكلام في العناوين لكن عندما تقرا
المتن همم لم يذهبوا بهذه الاتجاهات
الحاده حقيقه في مثل ما كتبوه يعني لو
تقارنا كذلك بالمقابل بين الصحف الاوروبيه
عندما تحدث اختلافات عندما يهاجم من قبل
دوله زارا
بطبيعه العلاقه المعروفه مع ايران يعني
عنوانه يعني بكل العناوين بكل هذه
موقف السيسي لا لا اذا تسمح لي اذا تسمح
لي اذا تسمح لي هنالك فرق بين المواقف
الرسميه وغير الرسميه المواقف الغير
الرسميه تبقى رايي وهذا الراي هو يعني هم
احرار بما يقولون لكن بالمقابل العلاقات
الرسميه هي علاقات مستدامه علاقات كذلك
عميقه نتيجه كون ال- ال- الوشائج ما بين
العراق ودول المنطقه هي كذلك عميسه
الحقيقه هو ان النظام التوجيه رسائل للسيد
محمد في السوداني ولابد انها وصلت وفهمها
كيف سيتصرف على اساسها
لا اكيد ال ال شوف هذه العلاقات لا تتاثر
بهذا المسار حتى هم الايرانيون يقولون
اليوم يعني صباحا في صحبهم التي نشرت في
ضمن هذه الاخبار ان العلاقات التجاريه
والعلاقات الاقتصاديه لم تتاثر به هذه
التصريحات الغير رسميه وهذا بالتالي دليل
الى انه هنالك فرق بين مواقف قد تكون لدى
هؤلاء الكتاب وبين كذلك مواقف الدوله
الايرانيه ان كانت يعني انه النظام
السياسي وكذلك الحكومه وكذلك مؤسسه وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه وبالتالي هنالك مواقف
واضحه جدا من دعم الحكومه من دعم كذلك
العراق ودعم كذلك بالمقابل سياسي لكن
بالمقابل تبقى هذه المواقف التي نشرت قد
تكون مواقف غير رسميه همم غير واضحه كذلك
المعالم باتجاه ما يحدث هنا في العراق وهو
عمليه التحول من همم اثار الحرب وانتهائها
وكذلك التعافي والانتقال الى السلام وهذا
ما يسال عليه
ذلك همم
ديمقراطيه القائمه في ايران وبالتالي لن
يعترض على ذلك لا مشكله لديه في ان تهاجمه
صحف دوله جاره هي غير عربيه لانه يتحدث
يعني مصطلحات تخدم عروبه العراق
لاكيد وليست تختم فقط عروبه العراق وانما
مصلحه الدوله العراقيه وهو مسؤول عنها همم
امام البرلمان
هو غير متضايق شوف
شوف اكيد اكيد هذا المسار لان شخصيه السيد
رئيس الوزراء الاستاذ محمد الشاعر
السوداني هو عمله كثيرا في وزاره حقوق
الانسان كوزير همم في الحكومات السابقه
وهو يعرف حريه الراي وحريه التعبير وكذلك
بالمقابل يحترم هذه الاراء لكن بالمقابل
المصلحه الوطنيه العليا للدوله العراقيه
هو ماضي بها وهو ماضي كذلك باتجاه حل
المشاكل العراق
في ايران يكون في مشكله لانه يعني الامور
ناخذ المواقف الرسميه لان الدول تاخذ من
المواقف الرسميه
والمواقف الرسميه يعبر عنها احيانا في دول
معينه بكتابات صحفيه هل باعتقادك بانه
يمكن ان يكون في خلف الامور ما يعني هو
مبطن وبالتالي هناك اراده سياسيه ما للضغط
على السيد شيعه السوداني في امور معينه لم
يلتزم بها حتى الان
يعني اكيد تبقى تبقى همم هواجز للنخب
الموجوده داخل هذه الدول المحيطه بين
حقيقتها وهي الدول الجوار السته تبقى
باتجاه سلوك الدوله العراقيه قضايا
واولويات الدوله العراقيه وكذلك رؤيه
الدوله العراقيه فيما يخص كذلك بالمقابل
تعاملنا مع التحالف الدولي وكذلك بالمقابل
اللقاء الذي اجري في وسط جورنا وكان لقاء
مهم للسيد رئيس وزراء وكذلك قبل له دبليو
همم
الوكاله الالمانيه للاخبار كذلك اللقاء
الذي كان مطولا عقبه زيارته الى المانيا
وكان الزياره مهمه جدا تحدث فيها السيد
رئيس وزراء اننا لا نريد قوه قتاليه لا
نريد كذلك بالمقابل ان همم
هذه القوات مفتوحه ولكن محدده في اطار
التدريب والتمكين وبناء قدرات القوات
المسلحه العراقيه والحرب على فنون التنظيم
الارهابي داعش وبالتالي مقاصد العراق واضح
جدا في هذا المجال قد يكون هنالك الدول
المحيطه بينا بما فيها ايران لديها رؤيه
لكن بالمقاب ان احنا ننظر الى المسرح
الوطنيه العليا للدوله العراقيه بالتجاه
السياسيه
الى المصلحه العليا لان الكتل السياسيه هي
التي تاتي برئيس الوزراء بالنتيجه وربما
تزيح عنه الغطاء قريبا اذا استمر في نهجه
العرب
لا اكيد القوى السياسيه العراقيه المشكله
لاتلاف الدوله حقيقه الان الداعم الى
السيد رئيس الوزراء وهو الائتلاف الذي
اعطى الثقه في البرلمان العراقي الى السيد
رئيس وزراء همم قد صوت على المنهاج همم
الوزاري وهذا المنهاج الوزاري همم واضح
جدا انه هنالك اتفاق بعمليه الذهاب الى
المصلحه الوطنيه العليا بدعم سياسه السيد
محمد الشاعر السوداني وكذلك بالمقابل
المضيبي اولويات المجتمع العراقي الاقتصاد
والتنميه والشباب وحل المشاكل الكبرى في
مقدمتها قضيه الكهرباء وقضيه التنميه شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور حسين علاوي مستشار رئيس
الوزراء العراقي من بغداد تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان وفي
جديد لازمه الوثائق السريه التي تطارد
الرئيس جوبيدر كشفت وطيت جورنال عن ان
وزاره العدل نظرت بالفعل في افريقيا عملاء
الاف بي اي بمراقبه عمليات تفتيش محامي
الرئيس عن الوثائق السريه لكنها تراجعت
وسبب هو تجنب تعقيد المراحل اللاحقه من
التحقيق خاصه
من سلموا دفعه الاولى التي تم اكتشافها
بسرعه لجهه المعنيه ولدي المحامين الشخصين
للتعامل مع الوثائق السريه وتنحيه اي موده
تصنف تحتها هذا البند كان المستشار الخاص
لبيض هو الذي رافق موظفي وزاره العدل
الاسترداد الوثائق بعد اكتشاف صفحات
اضافيه بعلامات التصنيف
لكن وبالعوده الى المحامين الخاصين ببيضن
كيف يمكن تركهم بمفردهم في مهمه حساسه
كهذه يوضح المدعي الفيدراليه السابق
لنيوزنيشن ان بعض المحامين الحاضرين في
عمليات البحث لا يعملون شخصيا لصالح بيضا
حتى لو كانوا من موظفي البيت الابيض ويشرح
ان مجموعتين من المحامين شاركت في التفتيش
الاول في التفتيش الاولي من مكتب مستشار
البيت الابيض وهم مدنيون او مدينون بواجب
الحكومه الامريكيه وليس لجوبايدن كشخص اذا
هم مدينون بواجبهم لصالح الحكومه وليسوا
مدنين لجوبايدن كشخص ولذا فانهم حين
يكتشفون شيئا ما يتصرفون كعملاء بمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي قد يكون هذا الشرح
بطبيعه الحال مقنعه لانصار بايضا لكنه
بالتاكيد غيره مقنع لانصار ترامب الذين
يتمسكون باتهام وزاره العدل بازدواجيه معي
في كل الاحوال التحقيقات في اولى خطواتها
بعد تعيين مدعام مستقل للتحقيق في هذه
الازمه لكن ماذا حدث في اخر قضايا مماثله
خلال تحقيق المدعي العام المستقل روبرت
مولر الذي نذكره جميعا في تدخل روسيا في
حمله 2016 وعن مد وجود روابط بينها وحمله
ترامب في الانتخابات حاول المحققون لاكثر
من عام اجراء مقابله مع رئيس ترامب قبل ان
يقبلوا في النهايه بشهاده مكتوبه محامي
رفض الاجابه عما اذا كان الرئيس سيقبل
باجراء مقابله مع المدعي العام المستقل
لكن حتى تصل الامور الى هذا الحد هناك امر
اخر يراهن عليه انصار بايضا لانهاء الملف
التقادم ناديه البلبيسي
لا تزالوا قضيه وثائق بيض تلقي بظلال
قائمه على البيت الابيض لكن هنا في وزاره
العدل الان تحقيق لا يزال مستمرا لكن
محامي عامل مع فريقه وترجيت الذي ادى الى
استقاله الرئيس روتشرد نيكسون يرى بان بيض
قد ينجو من ملاحظه قضائيه تجربه بسبب مرور
الوقت على حيازه هذه الوثائق فهي تعود
لفتره حكم بيض عندما كان نائبا للرئيس
والقانون يظبط هذه الفتره بحوالي خمس
سنوات لكن بعيدا قد لا ينجو من مسائله في
الكونجرس وملاحقه من الاعلام بسبب غياب
الشففي
معنى من واشنطن بيتر شاهين والصاد القانون
في جامعه نيويورك اهلا بك معنا استاذ بيتر
في العربيه 360 هل تقادم يمكن ان ينقذ
بعيدا فعلا من هذه الازمه التي هو فيها
موضوع الوثائق السريه
لا
يبين باي شكل من الاجواء انه هناك خطر
مزداقيه لان هذا الوضع مختلف تماما عامه
وجاهه الرئيس
المصنف سريه همم اولا في مكتب استخدامه
همم في همم في مؤسسته الخيريه همم عندما
همم
نائب الرئيس همم
الجريمه المحتمله همم
هذه الوثائق لها صله
بالاحتفاظ عن عمد بوسائقه سريه
وكذلك مواصله اخفاء هذه الوثائق حتى بعد
بعد ما طلب من الرئيس او نائب رئيس تقديم
هذه الوثائق ليس هناك اي مؤشرات في هذا
الوقت بان رئيس او محاميه قد اخروا باي
شكل من اشكال وحاول له اعاقه
التحقيقات او التعاون فيما يتعلق كثير شاف
هذه الوثائق القليله التي تم العثور عليها
في همم مكتب الرئيس او في همم
ولكن همم على الاقل موضوع تاجيل الاعلان
او الكشف عن هذه الوثائق السريه الى ما
الانتخابات النصفيه لربما يستحق تحقيقا
بذاته عندها تكون هناك شبهه حقيقيه قد
تورط الرئيس او بعضا من فريق عمله اليس
كذلك
بان
خصومه الجمهوريين
يحاولون اعطاء الصوره سلبيه بشان سلوك
الرئيس
هذه الوثائق اذا كان الامر كذلك بان
المحامين انتظروا الى اسبوع قبل الكشف عن
هذه الوثائق تظل الحقيقه ان الوثائق ثم
الكشف عنها للحكومه انه لم يكون هناك
مبيته لاخفاء هذه الوثائق همم هل يشفع
للرئيس بانه كان نائب للرئيس همم حينها
وبالتالي تكون ورطه الرئيس في حاله ترامب
مثلا بطبيعه الحال الاكبر
بالنسبه الي ربما
عدم التعرض لاي
ملاحقه ولكن هذا ليس بالامر الوارد ما
نعلمه في الواقع وما تم الكشف عنه هو ان
هناك عدد محدود من الوثائق تم العثور عليه
في عده اماكن رئيس
الحريه في الوصول الى احجام كبيره من
الوثائق المصنفه على ما دفع مني سنوات نحن
ندرك ان بعض هذه الوثائق لما ينتهي بها
المطافي في المكان التي كان يجب ان تكون
فيه طبعا هذا اهمال وليس هذا مبرر ولكن
الاهمال بحد ذاته ليس بالجريمه واذا ما
كان الرئيس همم او اذا ما تمت تم تحقيق مع
الرئيس وكشف التقرير انه لم يكن هناك اي
نيه
للاهمال المتعمد او اخفاء اي وثائق مصنفه
همم وانه لم يكن هناك اي محاوله ليعطاء
هذه الوثائق الى شخص ما كان عليه ان
ايطاليا على الوثائق وان كان هناك بعض
الجهود التي ترمي الى اعاقتي تحقيقات
لا يمكن ان يتهرب الانسان من اي شيء فار
رئيس يقول لم انه لم يرتكب اي جريمه على
شكل من الاشكال تمام
في جامعه نيويورك تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
التقى رئيس الجهاز المخابرات التركيه
هاكان زيدان مع رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
عبد الحميد الدبابه ورئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله في ليبيا خالد المصري في طرابلس
واشاره المشرفه تعود فيه الخلافات بقوه
بين الاطراف الليبيه الى نقاط اساسيه في
هذه المرحله متابعه
[موسيقى]
في ليبيا تضرب الخلافات جميع الاطراف
السياسيه في مقتل
فعلى القاضي اي اتفاق جديد يولد خلاف
الاخر وسط تدخلات خارجيه هذه المره ترمي
تركيا بثقلها في خلافات الغرب الليبي
وساطه تركيا بين رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه
ولايته هو رئيس المجلس الاعلى بين عبد
الحميد البيبا وخالد المشري مصالحه تمت
برعايه خالصه من رئيس المخابرات التركيه
الذي عقد اجتماعيا المنفصلين احدهما برئيس
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه والاخر برئيس المجلس
ليخت تتناب بلقاء صلح بعد الخلافات
الاخيره للانتخابات
سي يصرف المليارات ويقاتل عبد الحميد باي
بني منعها رئيس مجلس الدوله حدث بينه وبين
رئيس النواب تقارب اخر لكنه فشل بعد
تصريحات تعقيل صالح بان الاتفاق مع المشري
لا يتعدى ان يكون لفظيا تصريح قابله اخر
قطع ورقه الانعاش الاخيره بين شخصين لم
يتفقا يوما اصلا في وقت تعود فيه المياه
الى مجالها بين الدبابه والمشري الاخير
الذي ادعم فتح بشار بقوه ثم توسع الجفاء
ايضا بينهما لاحقا
تحركات تركيه في الغرب الليبي تقابلها
تحركات امريكيه اخرى شرقا وغربا حيث زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه الى ليبيا في محاوله للجمع بين
خليفه حفتر وقوتي العسكريه وعبد الحميد
البيبه وقوته سياسيه وذلك بعد اخر لا يغيب
عن التدخل التركي لتهدئه قيادات الغرب
وعقد هدنه بينهما في ظل الانتخابات
التركيه المرتقبه مع محاوله انقر المستمره
لايجاد موتى قدم لها في الشرق الليبي
وتامين مصالحها وسعيها للامساك بخيوط
التطورات السياسيه الليبيه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
فالعربيه 360 ايضا اردوغان يستدعي مقارنه
مع التاريخ او من التاريخ مع اسمن لطالما
احبه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تغريده عمرها خمس سنوات
حلقت في الفضاء الرقمي ب 140 حرفا لكنها
كلفت كثيرا كلفت الملياردير الامريكي
الشهيره الى الماسك 20 مليون دولار و20
مليون اخرى دفعتها شركه سيارات الكهربائيه
كسلار قال ماسك حينها انه يفكر في تحويل
تسلا الى شركه خاصه يبلغ سعر السهم فيها
420 دولار ثم ختمها بان التمويل مضمون لكن
القصه لم تجري كما اشتهى ماسك ففي البدايه
ارتفعت اسهم تسلى بنسبه 11% مع اللحظات
الاولى من نشر التغريده لكنها لم تصل ابدا
الى المستوى الذي وعد به والبالغ 424
دولار للسهم وبلغت اعلى مستوى لها في ذلك
اليوم عند
387$ و46 سنه وسرعان منخفضت الاسعار اسعار
الاسهم الى ما دون سعر ما قبل نشر
التغريده البال اختل 344$ حيث سجلت و 63
دولارا و24 سنه للسهم بعد شهر واصبح من
الواضح ان التمويل كان اقل من المامول مما
دفع المساهمين الى رفع دعوه وصلت الى
المحكمه في سان فرانسيسكو اليوم بدات
اجراءات المحاكمه عبر اختيار اعضاء هيئه
المحلفين الذين سيتعين عليهم تقرير ما اذا
كان ماسك قد كتب تغريد احتياليه عام 2018
كما يتهمون المستثمرون ام لا هكذا اعتدى
ماسك ان يكشف عن افكاره وربما عن الكثير
من سياساته دي سيل تغريدات لكنه لم يكن
يعلم ان المستثمرين ما زالوا عالقين عند
تلك التغريده خاصه وان حكما سابقا قضى بان
تغريده 2018 شهيره يمكن اعتبارها كاذبه
ومضلله وحينها ترماسك للتنحي عن رئاسه
مجلس اسلام مرغم وصل الامر الى حد مطالبه
الهيئه التي تشرف على البورصه المسبقه على
تغريداته المتعلقه بنشاط تسلا من محا من
متخصص
لايك ورده تسلم
حول سيارتي تسلا رائعه لانه بذل جهدا
كبيرا عدا ذلك اعتقد ان كل افكاره الاخرى
ضعيفه وهو يفعل ذلك فقط لكي يتحدث الناس
عنه يريد ان يلفت الانتباه اليه لذا ليست
كل افكاره ابداعيه الا في حاله تسلا
مبدعه انه رجل مبدع جدا لكن اظن انه رجل
خطير نوع لا اعرف لماذا لقد شعرت بذلك
لكنني اعتقد ان افكاره جيده جدا انه رجل
ذكي
هذا كل ما في الامر وانا اؤمن بذلك
كان في حاله ماسك وكنت قادره على ان تكون
مثمره وان تجني المال عليك ان تسال نفسك
هل كل هذا لي ام ان لدي مهمه لمساعده الاخ
وما المطلوب مني فعله بموهبه ليستفيد
الاخرون
اذا ماسك بين فكي تغريده او دات به الى
المحاكم اما يخرج منها منتصرا او يجر
اذيال الخيبه بعد محاكمه ستستمر عده سبعا
وابلغ القاضي ادورك هيئه المحلفين
المحتملين بان المدعينا يزعمون ان تغريدات
مصر كانت خاطئا من حيث الوقائع واثرت بشكل
مصطنع على سعر سهم تسلا واسهم اخرى وسبق
للقاضي ان رفضا نقل الاجراءات الى ولايه
تكساس الامريكيه حيث نقل ايلون ماسك مقر
شركه تسلا وجادل محامي ماسك بان
الملياردير لا يمكنه التمتع بمحاكمه
محايده في سامسونج فرانسيسكو حيث اشترى
تويتر في اواخر اكتوبر وتعرض الانتقادات
واسعه لقراراته من سياسه اداره محتوى
المنصه وصولا الى ما وصف بمجازر تسريح
الموظفين واكد المحامون بان الاعلام
المحلي اغرق في الاشهر الاخيره هذه
المنطقه بقصص متحيزه وسلبيه عن ماسك كتله
القانون والقاء اللوم عليه شخصيا في تقليص
عدد الوظائف لكن قصه ماسك مع تسله لن
تنتهي هنا فيبدو ان حلمه لمشروع القياده
الذاتيه يواجه عثرات عده يبدو ان ماسك
يقود تسلا او تقوده هي نحو حائط وعلى
الاغلب
المكابح لا تعمل
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والنيابيه
شهر رمضان التصريح للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي قال ان الامه التركيه سترد
على تحالف طاوله السته هنا تحالف احزاب
المعارضه يستدعي اردوغان مقارنه تاريخيه
فقبل ثلاثه وسبعين عاما في التوقيت ذاته
فاز الحزب الديمقراطي بالانتخابات
في صوره اليوم وهي من البصره خير البحر
مضمون ان بخوله الارض فنادرا ما تقصده ولا
تعود بالخير لن ننتظر نفط الارض لانه خرج
مره بعد مره ولم يصلنا ثمنه وحتى لم يجد
سكان القصور مشتريا لنفطهم فنفطنا نحن
سيباع طالما كانت هناك بطون خاويه
اما فيديو اليوم فمن روسيا وهذا هو رئيس
مجموعه يقولها بالفم الان لقد استفدنا من
قدراتكم الاجراميه في قتل العدو احتفل
بريكوجين بما اعتبره انجازات هذه المجموعه
من الجنود او بالاحرى السجناء الذين تمت
الاستعانه بهم في الحرب الاوكرانيه اكد
لهم انهم ماتوا احرارا يمكنهم الذهاب
للزواج او الدراسه او العمل فلم يعودوا
للسجون اما من سيراوده الحنين للعوده
للحرب باب قوات فاجنر الخاصه مفتوح هذا
بالنسبه لمن سيراوده الحنين الثاني الى
الحرب لكن ماذا
سيراوده الحنين للاول
نهايه العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه
مستمره من العربيه وموعدنا الان مع اخبار
الساعه سوهاجرين ينضم الينا صهيب مساء
الخير ماذا لديك مساء الخير اكمل من حيث
انت هذه هي تصريحات لبريكوجان يبدو انها
تثير المزيد من التفاعلات البيت الابيض
يعلق ويقول انه هناك مشكله بين روسيا بين
موسكو وبين قوات باكنروا وهذا ما تعكس هذه
التصريحات تمام نتابع تابع بعد قليل شكرا
[موسيقى]